Lara senko obviously she's super Dime
Piece right super dimes and then I guess
uh during the broadcast for at the
pre-show Daniel Cormier was
complimenting her for wearing the shot
Ramada hat thing I'll just play real
quick this is awkward or what hold on
yeah not too awkward you look beautiful
with that hat thank you like stunning
yeah you guys you gotten too far you
gotta chill she looks pretty huh yeah
but you gotta stop but she's my sister
she's like my little sister I can say
right yeah you're calling your little
sister hot I mean Laura you look
beautiful
hey you gotta stop hey hey pump the
brakes DC's like you I'm rock hard right
now no she's like my little sister white
was like
yeah there's just some bro talk she she
did look uncomfortable
hey shout out to Lauren saying yeah love
her